platform it's beginning to look a lot
like a chaotic Christmas for commuters
with rail strikes set to hit Services
across the country the biggest impact
will fall between the 11th and 17th of
December when just one in five trains
will run more walkouts are planned for
the new year at the same time bus
services will also be disrupted with
strikes planned for the next three weeks
the disputes are overpay and working
patterns and follow stalled talks
between unions and transport bosses a
fight fueled today by the transport
secretary who was clear despite demands
wages will not rise in line with
inflation I think inflation matching or
inflation busting pay Rises are
unaffordable and I think we want to try
and give all the workers in the public
sector who work very hard decent pay
Rises but they can't be inflation
busting pay Rises it isn't the money to
pay for those but at the same time by
the way we haven't seen those in the
private sector either this has angered
Union Chiefs who hit back telling Sky
News the money is there but the
political will is not the money does
exist that's the reality it's about
choices it's about where that money goes
and our view as a trade Union is a
public sector workers took us through
the pandemic and public sector workers
now deserve a pay rise a level of pay
that at least meets at least meets the
cost of living so that public sector
workers are not having to rely on food
banks but it's not just the transport
Network that faces disruption nurses
will also walk out for two days in
December the first time they've done so
in over a hundred years they say that
after over a decade of real terms paid
Cuts they deserve a 19 rise but even
labor couldn't say whether this is
Affordable in a Current financial
climate look the truth is I don't know
the government hasn't opened the books
to us so in the case of nurses for
example we're not privy to National
Health Service negotiations and it will
be absurd for me to try and conduct
those negotiations live on air what I
can tell you is that if we were in
government we would be treating the
nurses as partners they haven't been on
strike for 106 years and they've had to
resort to strike action because the
health secretary Stephen Barkley
wouldn't even meet them over the summer
thank you
after a summer of strikes many workers
will now be spending this festive period
on the picket line as well for the
public more discontent to come this
winter Liz Bates Sky News Westminster